Because strings are comparable, we can sort them by writing one line of code.
If I create an array list of strings and add a whole bunch of things not in any
order, and then I want to print them out in alphabetical order, I can add the
line collections.sort strings. Collections is a class a little bit like a race
that has some useful utility methods. If I compile and run this code, it will
print out all of the animals that I added to the list, but from A to W. We
might want to be able to sort countries like this too. Let's say countries are
naturally ordered by their areas. Let's implement the compareTo method for
countries. I want to be able to make an array of countries like this, and then
use the sort method in the arrays class to sort all of the countries in the
array, so that this will work. Let's implement the comparable method for
countries. We'll need to make the country measurable and also comparable. Now
the method should be public and return an int. It's called compareTo, and it
takes an object, otherObject. Now if we want to compare otherObject to this
object, the first thing we'll need to do is check whether otherObject actually
has a name and an area. If otherObject is not a country, then it doesn't really
make sense to compare it to this country. If you keep studying Java, you'll
figure out how to avoid this cast using generics. For now though, let's focus
on the compareTo method. For now, fill in the code, so that compareTo works as
I described before for countries. Return a negative number if this country is
smaller than other, positive is this country is larger, zero if the two
countries are equal. And notice, I implemented .equals for you. So, you can use
this. And if the countries are exactly the same size, you can break ties using
the name. Can you fill in the rest for me?